good morning Mr Wallace good to talk to
you again from uh here in Kiev first of
all
have we raised our nuclear deterrence
Alert in response to what President
Putin has done
well look um Mark the language that
President Putin has used doesn't
actually link to anything off a Russian
Readiness procedure it's really we
assess him putting the deterrent into
the communication space reminding people
that he has a deterrent and it's also
about distracting the world and the
public from what he's actually doing in
Ukraine it isn't it doesn't link to
anything specific in in their Readiness
structures of their forces so he he's
made this comment
um we keep it under review but of course
you know NATO has a nuclear deterrent
the United Kingdom is NATO's nuclear
deterrent but obviously we're joined by
France the United States and we keep our
Readiness very high that's why we have a
continued at Sea deterrent but you know
what we shouldn't really forget that
this is a big attempt to distract away
from his troubles in Ukraine by just
deploying into the sort of media space
these phrases
right but have you just to be clear have
you responded to what he's done in any
way in terms of our new I remember
comment on our nuclear deterrence
posture uh for operational and security
reason
do you think he's crazy enough to
instigate a nuclear conflict
yeah I I think he has certainly done a
lot of irrational things recently uh
obviously first and foremost the
invasion of Ukraine against all the
advice all the uh International lobbying
I think I'm not going to speculate on
what he would or wouldn't do but that's
why we all keep our deterrence at a
state of Readiness in the west to make
sure that we can deter
but do you think a cornered President
Putin would be a dangerous man
I think he's a dangerous man now
I mean if things got so desperate would
you think he could deploy tactical
nuclear weapons in Ukraine but Mark I'm
not going to head down a road of
speculation of what ifs with President
Putin what we know is that President
Putin is currently actually focused in
the invasion of a sovereign country in
Ukraine he is a man that has shown
himself to resort to all sorts of things
not least nerve agent on the streets of
Britain but I think he is focused with
this and I'm not I'm not going to go
into speculations about a nuclear weapon
systems or anything else I think that's
just not only unhelpful it's
unnecessarily alarmist when actually
he's focused his forces his military
leadership are focused on taking Ukraine
fair enough uh what do you think is the
latest intelligence what do you see as
the latest Intelligence on on how the
Russians are doing and when you think
Kiev could fall
I think your report is uh pretty
accurate we've just uh published our
daily tweet to the start or the first
tweet of the morning which gives us our
assessed in defense intelligence view of
where we are the the main bulk of those
armored columns that you've been talking
about are approximately 20 kilometers
north of Kiev Northwest of Kiev some of
the sporadic fighting is those sort of
stay behind or indeed Advanced forces
and I think you've covered on other days
still around but not having the
Strategic impacts that I think Russia
had hoped that airport that strategic
airport that you covered I think on the
first day that has changed hands a few
times clearly didn't get captured by the
Russians in the way that they'd like to
have used it and it's forced them to do
all sorts of things the Russians have
not captured the big cities like chernif
and karakoff up on the side up in the
north east of the country quite close to
some of their borders but they have made
better progress than their other forces
still behind scheduled in the South so
they're not on schedule they are in some
significant areas of disarray their
Logistics lines are therefore slowed
down and you know that's because they've
based all of this on this sort of
bizarre assumption that the ukrainians
would welcome them as liberators well
President Putin has taken that
assumption and now that is not the case
that's causing them to pause it's
causing them to have logistical trouble
and of course you've seen it firsthand
the the strong bravery of the ukrainians
and their determination to defend their
country and you know I visited that
country mark five times uh three times
security minister twice sorry three
times his defense minister twice the
security minister and you know if anyone
wants to know the dividing line between
ukrainians and Russia it is that
interview you've just carried with an
elderly gentleman who has signed up
about the views of people in his country
in Ukraine they recognize that
individuals matter their rights matter
and the ukrainian's view of Russians are
they don't count in the Russian game
it's simply just the powerful people in
Russia that matter
what would you say to Belarus there are
reports today that they are about to
send thousands of troops into Ukraine uh
to help the Russians what would you say
to them
well I think you know Belarus has a lot
more to lose by being closer to Russia
than it has to gain it is it is a very
poor country anyhow uh you know the the
the president uh pretty much ran off
scuttled really to Kremlin when he had
his Rising recently and has sold his
soul for that reason and now you have a
vassal State potentially On the Border
it won't help the belarusians it won't
help the Belarusian Armed Forces they're
far less equipped than the Russians they
are not as good they're not as well
trained and you know if I was a
Belarusian Soldier you should think that
President Putin will be the first to put
you in the front line because you are
absolutely easy to sacrifice uh compared
to Russian soldiers that he will think
might have a political impact on him at
home
and own weapons and supplying weapons to
Ukraine have you managed to get any
weapons into this country since the
invasion began
uh yes we've got lethal and non-lethal
Aid into this into Ukraine I can't
speculate where or how I think that
would be put people at risk the other
thing I've done Mark which is you know
Britain was the first European country
to step up to join America with lethal
Aid I hosted last Friday a donor
conference in Europe we've we've now
even got the belgiums and other
countries who historically would have
been hesitant delivering lethal Aid I'm
welcomed strongly the eu's position you
know it took quite a lot of us quite a
lot of effort since the but since the
but since the invasion began sorry to
interrupt you since the invasion began
have you managed to get yes weapons into
into Ukraine yes isn't the truth that
it's all a bit it's all a bit late
you've known that there's a threat to
um Ukraine certainly since 2014
shouldn't we have been arming the
ukrainians
for years in just you know because of a
possibility of something like this
happening
well first of all the United States have
been arming them since 2015 2014 they
were they were the first to do lethal
Aid straight after Crimea we
complemented that at first by training
20 000 uh uh ukrainians and also only I
think it was last year or if not 18
months ago we signed a contract with
ukrainians to supply them with fast
attack boats with missiles on them so
Britain was at the Forefront we were
also then the first European country to
do it but should overall the West after
2014 or maybe even after 2008 in Georgia
been more proactive in delivering uh you
know a stronger resilience package to a
number of states I think I think
obviously you know we can see now that
uh you know that that should have been
the case across Europe but Britain has
not been in that position Britain has
been in the lead of it you know I have
links with my defense counterparts
because I have visited so many times I
engage with them we give them military
support and will continue to do that but
I also think you know you have to also
recognize when you have a you're up
against President Putin uh you know that
his irrational Behavior which it seems
to be getting greater means it is
definitely harder to predict what was
happening you know I was there in
November I was there you know earlier
and even when he masked forces last
April on his border there were a
significant number of European countries
who refused to believe that he had any
intention apart from uh intimidation now
I think you know the West many countries
in Europe will now be regretting those
positions but fundamentally Britain has
been in the lead alongside the United
States in helping those ukrainians and
that's why we got to do the donor
conference on Friday and brought you
know 20 30 countries around the table to
deliver lethal and non-lethal Aid and
now we're at the heart of the
coordination of all those countries
getting it into the country
okay I just want to get a couple more in
do you support would you support British
volunteers coming over here to fight as
Liz trust is suggesting but I think Liz
trust is right to say it is definitely
for all of us a just cause that this is
this is about a sovereign Democratic
country being threatened or actually now
invaded by a Russian State and that is
something that we should all stand up
against whether that's at home I think
what I'd say is we can all do our bit
whether that's donating Paul through
through the Ukrainian Embassy I'd also
say that you know I our armed forces are
contributing in a proper way to to doing
this you feel Keen to help in your
United Kingdom citizen come and join our
Armed Forces there are lots of ways to
help look there are people who will go
better than volunteering to come and
fight well I think what I would say is
unless you are properly trained unless
you are a you know experienced member of
an armed forces I think you are there
are better ways for you to contribute to
the security off Ukraine in you know we
their travel advice the foreign office
is not to go to Ukraine you'll put
yourself in a Harm's Way if people are
determined to do that my advice to them
is there are many ways to help Ukraine
and unless you are a trained a military
personnel from a former career as in
you're not coming from our Armed Forces
because you've got a job to do here then
I would say I would advise you to
explore with Ukrainian Embassy ways to
do that
okay two more quick questions are we
going to reverse the decision to cut 10
000 troops from our uh military
well obviously Mark you wouldn't have
noticed because you're focused on other
things but a few weeks ago I announced
that the original Baseline of 72 and a
half thousand has gone up to another 573
000 and I've always said as the threat
changes we must consider changing the
current strength of the Army is 78 000.
but what I have to say is is something
to really recognize from what the
conflict we're seeing on our television
screens is I am not getting messages
from the ukrainians every day asking for
tanks I'm not out getting them asking
for armored vehicles I'm getting
messages every day from the ukrainians
asking for anti-tank weapons Personnel
carrot you know being able to be carried
by individuals I'm getting messages
every day about anti-air missiles that
can be carried by individuals that's the
type of warfare that is currently
threatening the might of the Russia
we're we're entering we yes we're
entering an era quite possibly of
confrontation with Russia and you are
effectively let's be honest cutting the
Army are you going to reverse are you
going to speak councilor to get some
money to refer to reverse the cuts to
the Army right so Mark there's no Cuts
other than Personnel there's an
increases to the Army's capabilities you
know the Army is it's not just about
people otherwise you end up the first
world war where you have millions of
people but you don't have any tanks the
key here is to get that balance so in
the Defense command paper we said a
number of things should happen one is
spend the money on the armed forces the
people we have to be better equipped
more than lethal more joined up and at
more Readiness otherwise you end up in
an army I was in where we had on paper
lots of Divisions but when you press the
button they were completely Hollow
because we ran out of money or we didn't
have quite the kit to deliver it so and
and the other thing your viewers should
understand I know they do that you know
country we're not a commentators said we
got an extra 24 billion pounds you've
got the biggest settlement increase
since the Cold War at the Defense
command paper that's not a cut in
anybody's book we have changed to some
extent the balance numbers of troops
it's it's a cut in numbers of troops and
I just want to finally just finally Mark
could you could you acknowledge it's an
increase in the defense budget would
that be useful if you could acknowledge
it's a increase in defense budget I'm
just a massive increasing about yes it's
a massive increasing the equipment I was
just talking about troops okay so what
we've seen in Ukraine let me just ask
you this
okay let me just ask you this because
we've run out of time I think on visas
shouldn't we be doing what the EU is
doing and allowing all Ukrainian
refugees in
well first of all what was announced or
will be announced later today is is a
first step we're absolutely looking at
all the different range of options we
can apply to to welcome ukrainians in
need the first step is to make sure that
ukrainians who have family here either
settled or are dual Nationals that they
can come and join them but the second
step we will look at about what we do
with the refugee flows across the board
um you know the Europe it's going to be
a problem right across Europe and we've
obviously seen the European position uh
change I think as of yesterday and we
will reflect that reflect on that and
and make make decisions uh in the near
future
so you may so you may do What the EU is
doing in fact I think what we'll do is
you know just like the size of the army
Mark we'll keep it under review
dependent on how situations changes on
the ground I think that's perfectly just
a bit remember Britain's been incredibly
generous with the Afghan scheme and the
arap uh which I was dealing with during
our pitting we've been a very one of the
most generous countries when it came to
obviously the Hong Kong Nationals so we
have a track record of being generous in
this area we'll make sure it's done
properly and we'll obviously keep it
under review as the facts on the grounds
change
okay we'll let you go good to talk to
you thanks for being with us thank you